a mission to the Antarctic has revealed
fossilized plant roots preserved deep
under the ocean since the time of the
dinosaurs
it seems this freezing landscape was
once home to a lush forest 90 million
years ago a temperate rainforest existed
in West Antarctica only 900 kilometers
away from the South Pole here hadden
clark's and his team set out on a ship
with a special drill to extract a core
of material stretching down 30 meters
into the sea floor when we recovered the
core we could already see what's inside
Aneta was very unusual and therefore we
decided to scan them in a CT scanner
back home so what we see here is that
the overview of the CT scanned core and
the yellow strata we see now is the
sandstone and now we transition into the
network of fossil roots and we can
nicely see how the roots are connected
with each other and our pristinely
preserved we have thin roots we have
thick roots and it's really a network as
you would go to the forest near you and
drill into the current forests studying
the core including analysis of
fossilized pollen and spores is
revealing more about the environment of
this ancient rainforest it revealed a
very warm temperature for this latitude
and annual mean temperatures that are
similar to those of northern Italy it
would be very certain that also
dinosaurs and insects lived in that
environment and in an environment that
was dark for about four months during
the year because we have the polar night
this was one of the warmest periods in
Earth's history with carbon dioxide
levels several times higher than they
are today
the new find provides a window into this
ice-free polar world and Johan hopes
that studying these past extremes could
help us prepare for the future these
extremely greenhouse climates
important for us to understand and in
full detail because it allows a look
into the future how the planet might
look like if we excessively emit co2 as
we do right now